I think the system is under strain and
we're seeing a manifestation of that as
many rise in the independent voter
registration I think the political
system if you look at here in Washington
from the governing standpoint it's
clearly broken we're gridlock on every
issue we fail to address issues of
irresponsible spending or Medicare
Social Security and we don't do any of
the hard things we spend we're in a
continuous battle over the war in Iraq
and partisanship and bitterness is
probably as high level as I've seen it
in all my years that we sit down
together for the good of the country I
know how to work across the aisle with
Democrats I have for many years as
president I will reach across my my hand
across the aisle to the Democrats and
I'll ask them to reach across to me and
I'll ask the American people to urgent
to do so if we get things accomplished
than dog ulam all the credit
Oh